el capitolio rodeado de barreras anti
manifestantes la policía se prepara así
frente a la manifestación de
simpatizantes de extrema derecha de este
sábado también teme choques entre
manifestantes y contra manifestantes
antifascistas a quienes donald trump
criminal hizo en varias ocasiones
ha habido algunas amenazas de violencia
asociadas con los eventos del sábado y
tenemos un plan sólido para asegurar que
permanezca en paz y que si hay violencia
podamos detenerla lo más rápido posible
no vamos a tolerar la violencia en
comportamientos delictivos de cualquier
tipo
justicia para el 6 de enero es el lema
de los organizadores de esta nueva
manifestación en apoyo a los encausados
por el asalto al capitolio de principios
de año se trata de un nuevo intento de
simpatizantes de donald trump y
movimientos de extrema derecha de
resignificar los hechos de aquel día
tras el día del asalto más de 600
personas se enfrentan cargos federales
presos políticos para los organizadores
de esta nueva marcha que afirman que se
manifestaron de forma pacífica
justicia para el 6 de enero es un evento
100% pacífico en apoyo a los
perpetradores no violentos que han sido
imputados desde el 6 de enero
matt weiner es el principal organizador
del evento antiguo analista del partido
republicano y ex asesor de donald trump
en la campaña de 2016 alcanzó mayor fama
tras la derrota de trump en 2020 desde
entonces busca presentar un relato
alternativo sobre el 6 de enero uno que
obvia el asalto violento al capitolio
las decenas de oficiales heridos y las
cinco personas que murieron aquel día